ergibt worten scheiße das sind diese
dieses opfer auf ich bin der totale dem
freund und herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge microsoft live in
the woods immer noch zusammen mit dem
vogel und dem frau die was zu essen
wir sind ein bisschen rum geflogen
glauben ist gras oder auch schon von
einer aufnahme bereit
passt ja zu dir ist ein blut wir haben
uns diesen wunderschönen ort gesucht
wir sind hier nah an einer wüste also
sehr trocken da hinten sehen wir aber
wunderschöne berglandschaften damals
gedacht das passt zu mir bergmann vom
bambuswald gefunden
das ist schon da hinten irgendwo glaube
ich ja im tiefen gras wie der sketche
hier sind so wunderschöne kleine sehen
überall und hier auch eine kleine lagune
ich zeige euch das mal ganz kurz
also ich nehme doch auch hier deswegen
soll halo galadiner sieht ganz schön
außer braucht man ein bisschen holz also
wir haben jetzt schon unsere erste
niederlassung gefunden
wir sind also ein bisschen durch die
gegend gefreut haben uns gesucht wo
können wir deine verschulden und uns
jetzt hier und jetzt bei jeder sein sein
häuschen aber der bergmann beschwert
sich schon die ganze woche das essen
braucht es stimmt allerdings jetzt
gedacht ich gehe jetzt mal gleich ein
herzchen aber dass herr schön gesagt was
kann man mit dem bambus eigentlich
machen sagt erhält hessen also ja ich
hab ich hab sogar wissen was willst du
denn was ja ich super gerne hättest du
hättest du musst ja super richtig
dankbar dafür ja ja aber mit mut auf ach
guck mal aus dem bambus kann man sich
zum bambus blöcke bauen die mit diesem
tag wieder ein weiß müssen wohl erst
grün reifen
ich habe schon versucht irgendwie samen
zu finden damit wir uns gleich weil brot
ist ja die einfachste methode um ihr
herr wie gegen aus dass mit dem reifen
ich glaube ich glaube ihnen also gemein
sind der grünen und ich glaube wenn die
ausgewachsen sind dann werden sie immer
grüne war jetzt bei mir ich werde mich
bei euch bei mir ist das hält der bei
mir ist das auch hell und der andere
dunkel hier genau genau genau und was
steckt übrigens ganz ganz viele neue sie
zusammen so verwegen apple entzieht und
reduziert und so ist das ich glaube
werden viele möglichkeiten haben uns
hier so ein bisschen ein paar früchtchen
das sind wohl so schön ich finde dass
dieser baum dass bäume die haben wir
diese herabhängenden blätter das sieht
wunderschön aus einfach vor allem
brauchen manchmal kommen diese partikel
darunter erweisen sollte er genau die
will ja genau
bäumchen wunderschöner ist also von
einer landschaftlich wunderschöne bei
nacht ist es echt das ist eine
zweiteilige liebe irgendwie bei tag
lieben wir das alles bei nacht dann
verschwinden sie wieder alles ist echt
an krank was wunderschöner mit dem
schädel zum laufen
das ist wirklich einfach so gedacht
vermutlich mal dass das auch irgendwie
so du hast so weil bei tag ein
entspanntes leben im wald ja und jetzt
anmelden
aber da waren ja ich kann auch englisch
und kann ja gut ich habe jetzt hier soll
ich einfach mal seinen wald anpflanzen
dass wir so ein bisschen holz kommt da
wo wir sind
hast du den lemmingen dabei also ich hab
mir grad zum baum gefällt und macht es
gerade die blätter kaputt sodass ich
setzlinge bekomme er ist nicht schlecht
denn ich kümmere mich darum mal essen zu
suchen
desweiteren einer straße schon neun
fleisch ist gut ich habe auch hühner es
heißt bedeutet mahlstein falls einer von
heute noch seine spitzhacke hört man
gerne steinhofen kann ihm ja gucken wir
erst mal aus holz machen
ich gab mich aber gleich irgendwo rein
hier ganz entspannt über die menschen
die erde auch so machen ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal die erde setzt die erde
irgendwo da in die wüste bei uns und
packt an den setzlingen das sieht
vielleicht ganz cool aus wenn also bäume
in der wüste stehen stelle ich mir ganz
cool volk macht das einfach mal war
mario lemieux
wer wird übrigens noch kein thema dabei
das ist jetzt einen unterschied zu den
darauffolgenden folgen weil
jetzt will ich erstmal bauen möchten und
so und auch dieser hashtag noch grad in
den kinderschuhen steckt und dann werden
wir vor nächsten aufnahmen könnt ihr uns
einfach allen bei twitter folgen also
aber luca wie hieß der noch mal der
hashtag verwehrt man das gar nicht ganz
leicht sagen der hashtag ist nämlich
hashtag wald liebe schreibt dass man
hier den chat rein so könnt ihr das
alles irgendwie schreiben oder halt so
das ist relativ egal
und dann könnt ihr uns da wunderschöne
themen sind aber lothar welchen
twitter-account soll ich dann folgen
allen allen voran bei jedem ach so
handel gut also dass ich mich gerade
wunder es gibt ganz verschiedene bambus
oliver musste vom bambus typen beim
bergmann grenze bei mir rum
ja ich bin ich bin halt ein blog
runtergefallen ist ein blog unter
gestiegen ja direkt ein halbes herz
wieder verloren ich muss jetzt essen
wurde es leicht ist das hier irgendwie
hat das hat es der serverhersteller so
heimlich auf hardcore angepasst nicht
irgendeine pflanze was ich komme zu dem
brand gekommen
geht man hier über die pflanze ist keine
animationen aber wenn ihr über gesten
einmal hier zu mir 'ich komme ich zu dir
geeilt und und dann sind auch hier auf
dem boden genau einmal alle schockiert
über die menschen wie sie sich manchmal
was ist das ich möchte auch schaden wenn
ich komme kommt hingegen wir sind
irgendwie vielleicht läuft er beim
kaktus kann er sein
da wo wir vorhin bei diesem
wunderschönen baum standen
ich will ich will viel vergiftet von den
pflanzen hier ich habe bei bezeugten
ließe sich ja hallo welt deutliche
schönheit kann ich gründen
ich weiß nicht wer da werde ich alles
sagt mir was braten ich mache hier so
einen kleinen imbiss auf hier gehen wir
über die wunderschöne das ist jetzt
vielleicht echt cool welche pflanzen
wieder auf da siehst so war uthopia
diese diese vergiftet männchen sind aber
auch böse ist frech aber wenn ich cool
dass da so ein paar fallen auch sind zum
einen baut euch da hinten jetzt hin
wir haben hier nur das lager
aufgestanden aufgeschlagen weil hier so
viele tiere waren sind ein bisschen was
auch beraten damit was ich auch ganz
cool findest du gesagt hast ja ich mache
ja einen kleinen laden auf so
metaphorisch gesehen ich fans wirklich
ganz cool wenn wir dann eventuell eine
zigarre in der anderen 20 blöcke weiter
weg in den anderen zehn blöcke wieder
weiter weg doch mal wieder so kleine
schöne wege dann in die mit kleinen
laternen nendaz da gibt es ja ganz viele
möglichkeiten jedes möbel angeht und zur
architektur und dann bauen wir dann
vielleicht wirklich einen kleinen laden
wo wir eine kiste reinstellen und da
sind dann kann man sich dann so sachen
holen wird besser
das ist wirklich so höre ich glaube ich
brauche mich hier ans meer an den see
kleinen laden aber ich mache dann
richtig dreckigen imbiss neben 50
kommunen sind zu einem unterhemd da und
es braucht eine currywurst ich kann
schon wieder von dem was gewissen
kleinen samen auf dem boden der muss
auch aufpassen die lieben kritisiert
dass dieser richtig böse für mich wieder
hier lernt man freut sich die ganze zu
diabolisch darüber dass er soviel
lebensfeindliche drin ist überhaupt
nicht erkannt wurde noch angst
diese haben oder wollen vielleicht noch
per twitter zu holen irgendwie war das
das gehirn schwarz thun das wird ja
immer schlimmer hier also ich fühle mich
gerade richtig bedroht überall so
achtmal das hühnchen läuft auch durch
diese bösen pflänzchen ist aber ganz
ganz ganz schöner wald mit normalen holz
und einem oder nicht doch mal rein und
bauen bisschen was ab ich hab ich gesagt
an diesem blut die ganze zeit sehr sehr
schockiert wenn ich ehrlich bin
das ist ja oben alles nicht klingen
es ist hier leute ich hab kohle hoch
ich habe eine biene ich hab euro freuen
ich habe eine kleine königin an einer
bienenkönigin eingesammelt liga tor
hatten wir das auch bei fiete wies daher
da hatte cavs eine riesige bienen fahren
da kann man auch richtig schön ertrag
raus machen also richtig schön zu machen
einfach das was wirklich hier so ein
kleiner im chor ich bin italia bis total
total der bienen fällen wissen ja viele
aufgehellter sicherheit nebenbei auch
noch teilzeit in kabul
ja jetzt nebenbei einfach eine biene
dafür hat es nicht immer um aufzunehmen
er soll die kohle bringen
kohle kohle kohle ich kommentiere zu
dieser zwischenrufen von kilos dann gehe
ich gleich ob ich glaube ich wollte
etwas schönes mit mit bambus gegen die
wieder zu bambus pfeiler im meer ich
weiß gar nicht geht dass das die mehr
power super das geht und sparkassen wird
ja dann setze ich die irgendwie auch von
bambus blog gesundheit stefan huster
aber ich kann nicht mehr aufnahmen
husten müssen weil hier los komm erstmal
nein ich hab so angst über
sondergleichen dreistigkeit
sondergleichen hab ich gesagt was meine
mutter das dass das team zieht ihr gar
nicht ich hab so aber alle sind böse
blüten aber kriegt man kriegt auch
wirklich sehr schnell fall der mitte
also irgendwas ist ja unangenehm
eingestellt nein das ist das nämlich
ganzen das integrieren
jaja achte man darauf den pflanzen fest
die sind einfach alle mega aggressive
die pflanzen rüsteten pflanzen haben wir
gehen auf das beste aber ich bin an
meine mum einem imbiss hier ja ich komme
zu dass es auch sehr schön dass das gras
hinter einem so beleuchtet wird
das ist ein bisschen wirklich ein
pokémon akku mal ist er dunkel ja das
kommt ja gar nicht ungelegen
ich schmeiß die kohle einfach mal ein
ofen
ich finde es ist wundervoll rostocker
schon kohle geschäftliche kohlhammer
17 ich vermute auch selbst wenn shader
nicht besser eingestellt bekommen wenn
wir dann in ausgeleuchtet gebieten sind
mit fackeln und so dann sollte das auch
gehen also wollen wir uns mal so eine
kleine bude bauen
in diesem zusammenhang haben alles ab
dabei alles ab wo wird zellmaterial
brothers war der vertrau mir kommt mit
hier hoch ich habe eine kleine
überraschung für dich sehr für euch ich
kann immer di di di di di como va die
königin hier bergmann ja nicht irgendwo
hinsetzen oder kann ich die essen oder
sowie die muss ich wahrscheinlich so ein
stamm rein sie es nicht schon ein
kleines loch hier können wir uns kurz
das ist einfach da gewesen wäre das
gemacht
schaut mal habe ich geige leuchtet ja ja
das ist schon eine red lights das echt
ganz cool ich bin mir total hell
vielleicht musst du einfach die fackel
tragen geht mir um eine fackel bitte ja
ja ich könnte auch das ist super drückt
man hier könnt ihr nämlich ausmachen ich
leuchte bei mir wie jesus wie dieses
skelett von frontex ist anders das macht
natürlich den schweren ist jetzt mal so
stark dass wir alle da hat man einfach
nur mit makel rumlaufen
trotzdem sagen das ist ja ganz kurz mal
ausleuchten der sieht ja wunderschön aus
das ist ja mal richtig starkes habe mich
schon freuen dass ihre folge geschrieben
dann war das dann war das ja gar kein
vieler quasi in unserem shaders und das
ist so gedacht ist das schön manager
bergmann
das soll ja sagst ja ich dachte es kennt
ihr du wir sind hier schlecht wie eh und
je eben
wir bauen das jetzt mal ein bisschen
schöner das haben uns auch unter bauern
vorgestellt einfach in den berg rhein
mit kumpels dauern
jedoch gibt sich direkt wieder nach
draußen nein
dann würde ich auch sagen wir versuchen
irgendwie gibt es scharfe ja ich hab
schon scharf wer wissen wolle schuldigen
aber ich weiß nicht ausgemacht dass ist
das ist echt eigentlich ganz cool sogar
aus also ich finde es klasse
ich glaube ich dass in china wirklich so
drin das ist schön mit denen sätze ich
irgendjemanden
verbesserungsmöglichkeiten richtig gut
ist oder so wie ich das eigentlich auch
ganz angenehm ihr ich habe nachgefragt
der letzten episode noch aber da musste
ich das mit denen die namensschilder
holz holz holz ich hab euch bitte schön
da nichts liegt vor dir danke lieber das
holz von ihm ist angekommen
redmond möchtet ihr dem bauen gerade
wollte ich nur eine spitzhacke für mich
bauen das jetzt ein bisschen bisschen
stein über eine barriere bisschen raus
ppr starte das toro ende beide länder
seien dabei in allen ländern ende märz
allerdings soll ich ihnen auch noch hieß
da kann ich nicht rein hab mich
angeguckt
boa der blutet lila guckt euch das mal
an da sieht man einfach die kinos
rauslaufen oder jacken er ist voller
motivation der zwischen hoffen und kommt
direkt wieder raus oder rein lässt sich
auch die hälfte in meinem text abegg die
sie auch richtig viel los bei mir doch
so streifen bei mir da komme ich kann
auch ein kleines schwert machen ja
durchsuchen sie sind so ein jahr so ein
stein schwer
ich habe jetzt einfach so eine böse
pflanzen uns vorgesetzt kate und kate's
läuft erstmal direkt rein hier über den
mittlerweile ist jetzt dadurch
geschwächt und danke du kannst ein altes
haben ein eigenes dass diese pflanzen
und tiere komm her eine gala freuen sich
richtig einen auf assassin machen
achtung ihrem zweieinhalb leben ich
brauche zu essen
hast du dich einmal aufstellen stimmt
ihm treffen glaubt dass ganz essen
mitgenommen hat das irgendwann gemacht
nee ich hab alles dabei wie sollen wir
so einen komischen pfeiler ist das für
die statik wichtig ja dass das erstmalig
fand das von das fand das irgendwie man
kann ja schon mit ein bisschen ästhetik
anfangen obwohl ich das sieht so schön
aus dem 18 bergmann
treki noch so was nie gekommen da kann
man durch gucke dann sieht er aber
wunderschön aus dem gefängnis fühle ich
mich gerade wunderschön aber er geht aus
der schönsten gefängnis das wir jemals
gesehen hast ja bergmann möchtest du mal
die seife aufheben natürlich da rauskam
und frieda familie süß ist es blut hier
was hab ich getan ich habe den keeper
aber der stirbt an dieser an dieser
grenze weil ich dadurch den pflanzen
bleibt mal ruhig hier alles taktik
durchgeplant man sich super natürliche
fallen bauen und was ist das eigentlich
trotzdem kann man jedes maß an
begeistert ja das ist mal ins hirn was
hast du eigentlich gerade mein super
natürliche fallen verarscht mich
überhaupt nicht
das war gar nicht eingesperrt was diese
kommt es aber auch ab ich finde das hier
ich will hierbleiben
ja wir bleiben für immer hier erwarten
wenn die nachbarn vorbei wir machen
wollen und machen einfach auslaufen der
folge klappen wenn ich noch ein bisschen
raus durch die pflanze durch starke
posten genannt habe diese dynamik
leitung also könnte gar nicht sehen weil
das ja lukas folge aber bei ihm eher der
in ewigen trader wie ich drauf sehen
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal eine fackel
in der hand
das ist ja also das ist ja schön auch
dass diese fackeln die man in die umwelt
setzt sie machen nicht so viel hier aber
es sieht auf jeden fall wunderschön aus
ich bin für dich aus ist wir sind alle
sehr begeistert von dem motto pack und
und wahrscheinlich spielt er das
alltäglich mit diesem ganzen denkt an
den ersten paar episoden aktuell
kommentare fähig als sie das schön aus
und hier und ob ihnen haben leuchtende
augen bei mir ist in meinem haben so
gelbe leuchtenden augen aber ich habe
nur zwei ich bewahre zu essen auf jeden
fall ist ganz kurz zurück aber das ist
ja menschlich das tier wieder hier
wieder ab mittels hier jetzt mal ganz
gut was zu fressen
soll ich euch mal was mitbringen
vergiftet worden scheiße das sind diese
diesel es doch mal auf ich bin der tod
bin erst klein wenig zum hinter dir ich
kann ich kann ich sowieso hätte
natürlich dem singleplayer kommt es mir
besser funktioniert nicht mit du dich
mit mir kurz mit ich hab ich habe
vielleicht fleisch kommt schnell hatte
ich muss einfach ganz schnell wieder ich
muss ganz schnell unsere bude keine
sorgen ich habe alles hindert die
aufgeräumt okay okay ich mache die
richtigkeit
bisher hat und bin vergiftet kommen hier
kommen hier lieber zuerst romani
daran will was zu essen ich meine
inventar ist wohl mal wieder zu mir du
bist in sicherheit genauso wie diese
folge auch jetzt langsam zu ende ist
eure zeichen hier versteckt in münchen
hinter mensch ich würde sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat dass
schön für den endkampf letztlich
gefallen hat könnt ihr gerne eine
bewertung da lassen und uns dass darüber
zeigen und sonst würde ich sagen kommt
die nächste folge morgen beim bergmann
kommt es zu beschreiben und dann
schreiben wir auch wenn wir aufnehmen
für themen bei twitter und natürlich
sagen tschüss von meiner seite aus ihnen
weshalb beiden ja wie es nochmal der
hashtag der hashtag hieß wald lebende
bergmann ist ein bisschen vergessen
nicht ich denke ihr auch deswegen am
besten hinter die ohren schreiben
sondern ganz viele themen schreiben über
die wir dann quatschen vernünftige
themen meine lieben freunde
alles was hier alles voll alle